قابل كيتون نيوجرن ، إنه طالب قانون
من جونستاون ، وكان قد تدرب سابقًا
مع السناتور جوني إرنست كيتون ، جيد جدًا ، مرحباً
السيد نائب الرئيس ، سؤالي هو هل
أنت مستعد للرد على
الرئيس السابق بشأن مزاعم كان
من الممكن أن تقلب انتخابات 2020
سأحيلك إليها  خطابي اليوم
يجيب على هذا السؤال والإجابة
نعم
لأنني أعتقد أنه مهم
ولكن ليس لأنني لم أعتقد أنه كانت هناك
مخالفات في انتخابات 2020 التي
قمت بها
وقلت ذلك في ذلك اليوم المشؤوم كان
لدي مخاوف من وجود نصف
عشرات الولايات التي غيرت القواعد
باسم covid
وقوضت ثقة الجمهور
في انتخاباتنا ولكن بمجرد أن
صدقت الولايات على تلك الانتخابات بمجرد أن
راجعتها المحاكم بمجرد
نظر الكونجرس في أي اعتراضات ،
علمت أن واجبي كان واضحًا ينص
الدستور  من الواضح أن
وظيفة نائب الرئيس كرئيس
لمجلس الشيوخ هي رئاسة
جلسة مشتركة للكونغرس حيث
تفتح أصوات الهيئة الانتخابية ويتم عدها
وتقول إنها ستفتح وسيتم عدها وقد
فعلنا ذلك
وأريد الأمريكي  الناس يعرفون
أن أه أؤمن من كل قلبي بأننا
قمنا بواجبنا في ذلك اليوم
يقول الكتاب المقدس إنه يحافظ على يمينه حتى
عندما يكون ذلك مؤلمًا وأنا أعرف شيئًا عن
أن دونالد ترامب يقول إنه
يميل إلى العفو عن العديد من أفراد
الغوغاء الذين  هاجموا مبنى الكابيتول في
6 يناير. كان هؤلاء الأشخاص بالطبع جزءًا من
نفس الغوغاء الذين بنوا مشنقة
وهتفوا عن رغبتهم في شنقك ،
هل تفكر في الاحتفال
والعفو عن أي منهم
تعرفه في يوم 6 يناير ، لقد
أصدرت تغريدة
تطالب بذلك  الناس يغادرون مبنى الكابيتول
ويوقفون العنف
وقلت إن أولئك الذين فشلوا في القيام
بذلك يجب أن يحاكموا إلى أقصى
حد يسمح به القانون
وما زلت أعتقد أنه
لا يمكننا اليوم أن نسمح لما حدث في
6 يناير أن يحدث مرة أخرى في القلب
من ديمقراطيتنا وسألتزم بالقرارات
وإجراءات المحاكمة العادلة
في قوانيننا وليس لدي أي مصلحة أو
نية
للشراكة مع أولئك الذين اعتدوا على ضباط الشرطة
وخربوا عاصمتنا ، فهم بحاجة إلى أن يكونوا
مسؤولين أمام القانون ،
لذلك أريد أن أسأل  حول بعض
الأخبار العاجلة الليلة ، أبلغت وزارة العدل
مؤخرًا الفريق القانوني لدونالد ترامب
أنه هدف
لتحقيق اتحادي في احتمال إساءة التعامل مع
المستندات السرية ، يجب أن أقول إنه
تم تبرئتك الأسبوع الماضي في
قضية المستندات
الخاصة بك.  سيدي حسناً
دعني أقول أن التعامل مع المواد السرية
هو أمر خطير للغاية
ولهذا السبب بعد الكشف
أه
في مقر الرئيس وكشف
أن مقر إقامة الرئيس السابق
أخذت على عاتقي
مراجعة ملفاتنا
وكشفنا عن جزء
صغير  عدد الوثائق التي
تم نقلها عن غير قصد إلى
سكاننا في ولاية إنديانا
أبلغت وزارة العدل على الفور وأه
أنا ممتن بعد تعاوننا الكامل
أنهم خلصوا إلى أنه
كان خطأ بريئًا هل ترى أن
قضيته مختلفة ولكن دعني أقول هذا
انظر أنا
لا أعرف حقائق
قضية الرئيس
قضية الرئيس السابق
أم وإه
لكن ما لدينا في هذا
البلد هو معاملة متساوية في ظل القانون
وقد لا تعرف دانا  أعني أنني كنت
مضطربًا جدًا في الصيف الماضي عندما كان هناك
أمر تفتيش لأول مرة في التاريخ تم تنفيذه في منزل
رئيس سابق للولايات المتحدة ، ومن
المؤكد أنك تعرف كل السنوات التي خدمتها
في اللجنة القضائية عندما كنت
أنت و  قابلت لأول مرة أنه
كان لابد من وجود عشرات الطرق التي
كان من الممكن التعامل معها بخلاف هذا
النوع من السلوك ، أعني عندما أبلغت
وزارة العدل بأننا قمنا
بتصنيف المواد التي يحتمل أن تكون في
منزلنا كانت في منزلي ، وكان مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي في
منزلي.  عتبة الباب الأمامي في اليوم التالي
ما اكتشفناه هو أنه عندما قام جو
بايدن على ما يبدو بتنبيه وزارة
العدل بعد 80 يومًا ،
ظهروا في مكتبه ، فهذه ليست
معاملة متساوية بالتأكيد بموجب القانون
ولكن السؤال هو الادعاء
بأن التحقيق في العرقلة  من
الواضح أنه لم يفعل إذا كان هذا
أمرًا يراه المحققون
ممكنًا وحتى بما يكفي لإدانة
الرئيس السابق ، هل تعتقد
أن هذا يجب أن يمضي قدمًا
بشكل جيد ، أتمنى ألا أفعل ذلك
حقًا لنانا
أعني أن
هناك عدة أسباب لذلك الرقم
واحد  هل أعتقد أنه
سيكون أمرًا مثيرًا للانقسام بشكل رهيب للبلد ،
أعني في وقت
يتأذى فيه الشعب الأمريكي ، أعني أن أقول لكم إن
العائلات تكافح الآن مع
تضخم قياسي لدينا
أزمة في مجلس أمثالنا
لم نر من قبل أن لدينا فيضانًا
من الفنتانيل يأتي إلى كل مدينة كبيرة
وصغيرة في هذا البلد ويقتل
الشباب كل يوم لدينا تهديدات في
الخارج موجة جريمة في مدننا أعتقد
الآن أكثر من أي وقت مضى أننا يجب أن
نجد  الطرق التي يمكننا من خلالها أن نجتمع
معًا وهذا النوع من
الإجراءات من قبل وزارة العدل
أعتقد أنه لن يؤدي إلا إلى
مزيد من الانقسام في البلاد ، واسمحوا
لي أيضًا أن أقول
أعتقد أنه سيرسل أيضًا
رسالة مروعة إلى العالم الأوسع ،
أعني أننا
نحن شعار الديمقراطية ، نحن
رمز العدالة في العالم ، والأمر
الخطير الذي حدث بالفعل
مرة واحدة في نيويورك إنني أدين
رئيسًا سابقًا للولايات المتحدة
يبعث برسالة مروعة إلى  العالم ،
آمل أن يفكر الدوج في الأمر بشكل أفضل
ويحل هذه القضايا بدون
لائحة اتهام سيدي ، أريد فقط أن أوضح
ما تقوله هو أنه إذا كانوا
يعتقدون أنه ارتكب جريمة ،
فلا ينبغي لهم المضي قدمًا في لائحة الاتهام ، هل
تحدثت للتو من قبل  بشأن عدم
الالتزام بسيادة القانون ، اسمحوا لي أن
أوضح أنه لا يوجد أحد فوق القانون بخير
ولكن فيما يتعلق بالظروف الفريدة
هنا ،
وبالنظر إلى
هؤلاء المصنفين ، لم يكن لدي أي عمل
لديه وثائق سرية في إقامتي
وقد تحملت المسؤولية الكاملة عنها
لم يكن لدى الرئيس بايدن أي علاقة
بإقامته في مقر إقامته منذ أن كان
نائبًا للرئيس
وكذلك الأمر نفسه مع الرئيس السابق ترامب ،
لكنني آمل فقط أن تكون هناك
طريقة لهم للمضي قدمًا
دون
الخطوة الدرامية والقاسية والمثيرة للانقسام.  عند اتهام
رئيس سابق للولايات المتحدة ، علينا أن
نجد طريقة لدفع بلدنا إلى
الأمام واستعادة الثقة في
المعاملة المتساوية بموجب القانون في هذا
البلد ، نحن حقًا [
تصفيق]
ورئيسك المنتخب ، هل
ستعفو عنه
جيدًا. أنا  لا أريد التحدث عن
الافتراضات ،
لست متأكدًا من أنني سأنتخب
رئيسًا للولايات المتحدة ،
لكنني أعتقد أن لدينا فرصة قتالية ،
وأعتقد حقًا أننا نفعل
شيئًا آخر قلته في
إعلانك اليوم.  أي
شخص يضع نفسه على
الدستور لا ينبغي أبدًا أن يكون رئيسًا
للولايات المتحدة ، مشيرًا بوضوح
إلى الرئيس السابق ترامب بعد ساعة ،
فإنك تتعهد بدعم
المرشح الجمهوري في نهاية المطاف ، لذا إذا كنت تعتقد أن
دونالد ترامب يجب ألا يكون أبدًا رئيسًا ،
فكيف يمكنك الالتزام بدعمه
إذا كان المرشح
حسنًا ، دعني أقول إن ما قلته اليوم هو
أن أي شخص يضع نفسه فوق
الدستور لا ينبغي أبدًا أن يكون حاضرًا
في المقام الأول
وأي شخص يطلب من أي شخص آخر
وضعهم على الدستور
يجب ألا يكون رئيسًا مرة أخرى.
آمل أن يأتي الرئيس ترامب
حول اختلافنا حول ذلك
اليوم المأساوي وحول دوري
وما زلت آمل أن يكون
أعني أنه سيكون لدينا خلافات
تستحق المناقشة ولكن
في جوهرها من المهم أن
نتذكر
رئيس الولايات المتحدة
تقسم الولايات على دعم
دستور الولايات المتحدة
والدفاع عنها وتنفيذ القوانين بإخلاص ،
ولكن في جوهر ذلك هناك استعداد
للخضوع للحكمة
الجماعية لأجيال من
الأمريكيين المنصوص عليها في
دستور الولايات المتحدة
وأنا أحمل  ترى أنه
يجب أن يكون شرطًا أساسيًا لأي رجل
أو امرأة سيتولى منصب
الرئيس أن توافق على ألا
تضع نفسك فوق
الدستور
فيما يتعلق بدعم مظهر
المرشح الجمهوري ، لقد
بدأت في السياسة كديمقراطي
ولكن بمجرد  لقد سمعت صوت ومُثُل
الرئيس الأربعين للولايات المتحدة ،
انضممت إلى ثورة ريغان
ولم أنظر إلى الوراء أبدًا ، وكنت دائمًا
أؤيد المرشح الجمهوري
لرئاسة الولايات المتحدة
وسأدعم المرشح الجمهوري في عام 2024
خاصةً إذا  أنا بخير
[تصفيق]